PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Have you ever wondered
if you could just
upload an FAQ document
and a chatbot would
magically be created
to answer those questions?
Well, keep watching
to find out more.
Welcome to
"Deconstructing Chatbots."
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this episode,
we will explore Dialogflow's
Knowledge Connector feature.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
At the time of this
recording, Knowledge Connector
is a beta feature
within Dialogflow.
Knowledge Connector
complements the defined intents
by parsing documents
such as FAQs or articles
to find questions and responses.
Questions are added
as training phrases,
and answers are
added as responses.
To configure them, you define
one or more knowledge bases,
which are collections
of documents.
At the time of this
recording, CSV and HTML files
are supported for ingestion.
Let's jump into our
Dialogflow console
and see how to set it up.
Use an existing agent
or create a new one.
If you do not know how
to create an agent,
refer to the third
episode of the series
where we are building an
appointment scheduler.
Because this is a
beta feature, we
start by going to the gear icon
and enabling the beta options.
Now we are ready to create
our Knowledge Connector.
Select the Knowledge
beta from the left pane
and click Create Knowledge Base.
Give it a name and save.
Now we need a knowledge
document that we can use
to auto-generate the chatbot.
I have opened this Compute
Engine FAQ here as a sample.
Let's use this one.
Let's go back to
our Dialogflow agent
and create our first
Knowledge Connector.
I'm calling it
Compute Engine FAQ.
Select a Knowledge type.
It is FAQ in this case.
Select a MIME type.
In this case, it is HTML file.
And we add a URL
to this document.
Once you have
filled, click Create.
And just like that,
the Knowledge Connector
has created the FAQ chatbot.
Let's click on our
Compute Engine FAQ.
We see that the questions
are parsed into requests
and responses neatly.
Click on Add Response to
enable the automated responses.
That's all, just save.
Before you test, make sure
you have enabled the chatbot.
Click on the checkbox beside
the name of the FAQ and click
Enable.
Now we are ready to test.
In the simulator
on the right, query
your Dialogflow agent with, what
is pricing for compute engine?
And you will see a
response from the bot.
Try out more examples
like, how do I get support?
You will notice that I did not
type the exact same question
from the FAQ, and it still gets
mapped to the correct intent.
That's the beauty of
Knowledge Connector.
Today, we learned how to create
an FAQ chatbot from an HTML
or CSV file in less
than two minutes.
Try this awesome beta
feature and create
some chatbots to answer those
FAQ questions automatically.
Once you do, don't forget to
share the experience with us
in comments.
I hope to see you in the next
episode of "Deconstructing
Chatbots."
If you liked this
video and would
like to see more
such content, don't
forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]